what's been happening over the last 10
days with Wagner is extraordinary I mean
it's it's almost beyond belief that
they're just completely out of control
yeah so they they kidnap the commander
of a battalion as Lieutenant Colonel
beat him up forced him to do a prisoner
style hostage Style video confessing to
ordering the shelling of Wagner troops
while he was drunk then when he was
released this Colonel said by the way
Wagner regularly tortured kidnap and the
Russian troops and steal that ammunition
and stuff so little surprise that
yesterday Putin's actually put his
imprimatur on trying to rein in Wagner
but so far Wagner is showing their signs
of submitting to Putin's word